When you're falling. All you can hear is your
heartbeat.
It's been beating since the moment you were
born, and you never paid it any mind.
And now... the last thought that pops into your
head,
right before you hit the ground.
You should have listened to it while I still had the chance.
Because if I'd listened to that heartbeat,
maybe none of this would have happened.
I'm sorry.
What did fucking happen in this play? This
woman got choked with a rattle and thrown off
the top of the Pickwick Lighthouse. And our
audience is supposed to think a baby is my
prime suspect?
Well, yes and no. Because-.
Well, what is it, Oliver? Because I don't live in the gray.
Cobro doesn't live in the gray.
Is he a cobra? Yeah. Is he a bro? Yeah.
That's how you gross two bill.
Not with subtle. Subtle doesn't sell.
First of all, do you see this paisley neck cloth?
I have never been accused of being subtle.
And second. Ben. Ben, rehearsal is a process.
This is our first week with this material.
When the curtain goes up in three months on
opening night. Trust me, you're going to
kill.
No, he definitely died the second time. Oh,
shit. I've got to go.
Oh, KT.
KT! KT, wait.
Wait. Okay.
Why are there people out there striking our sets?
Sorry, Oliver. I've got my orders.
Well, I'm ordering you to stop. This has to
stop!
Thank you.
Now, I'm going to call my producer and show
you that we are all on the same page.
You've reached Ceo and founder of DeMayo productions.
Okay.
Well, I'll try the other producer, the son.
Hi, it's Cliff Demayo. I am also a
professional.
Okay, the reception here is dog shit.
They're pulling the plug, Oliver. They just
don't want to say it to your face.
Well, then I need to go to them, and she's
going with me!
And you can tell those workers on stage right
now that if anyone lays another finger on my
sets, I'm going to wrestle them too.
And Oliver Putnam never taps out!